--
HiHier soir, nous étions tous
prprivés à n nos téléphones. Dor
ArArruda qui part, qui a
dédémissionné. Je vous fais
enentendre tout de suite M.
LeLegault. Il a repris cette
foformule à p plusieurs reprisen
coconférence de presse : il y a
dadavantage davantage, il y a ps
d'd'avantages que d'inconvéniens
àà a avoir quelqu'un de nouveaun
écécoute.
- - Je l'ai toujours dit, puis e
l'l'ai dit clairement au nouveau
didirecteur national; ça reste
mama priorité le retour à l l'é.
AÀ partir du moment où on a
didiscuté, on s'est mis d'accord
llà-d-dessus.
- - À partir du moment où il a
coconvenu, il parle de Monsieur
ArArruda qui a convenu, c'est ue
didiscussion avec le premier
miministre Monsieur Arruda. Ce
n'n'est pas une démission
ququi a été lancée seule dans ue
chchambre en disant : je dois
papartir. Le bureau du premier
miministre a eu des contacts avc
lului et là c convaincu que c'ét
lala meilleure chose. Josée?
- - C'est à p peu près s imposse
sasavoir le contenu, le vrai
cocontenu des discussions. Ce st
dedes discussions très privées
auaussi. Ça a été quoi si je pex
didire le input du ministre de a
sasanté Christian Dubé, on sentt
soson agacement depuis des mois
avavec certaines Hanssèzeze Docr
ArArruda. C'est clair que c'est
ququelque chose qui a été comme
vovous dîtetes bien préparer, bn
huhuilé et pour des raisons dont
onon pourrait discuter pendant s
papanel. Pour des raisons
esessentiellement politique.
- - Est-ce que ça s'imposait?
EsEst-ce que c'était la chose à
fafaire d'après s vous?
- - Sur le fond des choses, oui.
MoMoi, je fais parti de ceux et
cecelles... on a de plus en plus
d'd'experts qui se disaient très
dédéçus de plusieurs prises de
poposition du Docteur Arruda sur
dedes questions fondamentales ds
lala gestion de la pandémie. Jee
paparle pas Jésus masquais dansa
prpremièrere vague. Depuis, ça a
vrvraiment persisté jusqu'à t tt
rérécemment où le Docteur Arruda
didisait que les masques 95
ététaient moins sécuritaires que
dedes masques de procédure alors
quque la science dit exactemente
cocontraire. Sur le fond des
chchoses, je pense que ça ne
tetenait plus depuis longtemps.
LeLe premier ministre surtout
enentre les mains depuis quelqus
momois des sondages qui montrent
etet les légers d'aujourd'hui le
coconfirme, il y a un glissemen,
unun lent glissement de la
coconfiance de la population
enenvers sa gestion de la
papandémie. Et comme Monsieur
ArArruda y est aussi associé
ététroitement, Monsieur Arruda t
papassé à l la trappe.
- - Alec, comment vous comprenez
leles dernièreres 24 heures?
- - Je pense que ça se tramait
dedepuis plus de 24 heures. On
avavait envoyé du côtété du
gogouvernement des messages à
HoHoracio Arruda dès s la fin du
momois de novembre qu'il était
pepeut-êtrtre dû p pour prendreu
rerepos parce qu'il travaille st
jojours sur sept presque 16 heus
papar jour depuis très s longte.
EtEt on commençait à l le juger.
C'C'est une préoccupation
coconstante dans l'entourage
prpremier ministre, tous ceux qi
trtravaillent sur la gestion dea
crcrise, que ce soit Christian
DuDubé et les conseillers de
FrFrançois Legault, on leur
dedemande : est-ce correct? As-u
bebesoin de repos? Le jugement t
afaffecté par la perte de somme,
lele trop-plein de travail.
MoMonsieur Arruda disait toujous
: : je suis correcte. Et il
acacceptait, dès s qu'on lui
dedemandait quelque chose peu
imimporte l'heure du jour de
l'l'année, il acceptait. Dès s a
fifin du mois de novembre, on a
trtrouvé que ça commençait à  êe
dédécousu autant en privé qu'en
pupublic, c'était plus compliqué
dede justifier certaines mesure.
OnOn avait de la difficulté à
susuivre Horacio Arruda. On pare
dedes masques N95, mais sur les
tetests rapides, ça a pris du
tetemps avant que Québec disait
ququ'on devrait en utiliser
dadavantage. On a mal à p prépar
lala vague Omicron. Horacio et n
éqéquipe disait : on a
susuffisamment des protections
vavaccinales parce qu'on a donné
dedes deuxièmemes doses espacéer
rarapport au premier alors que
dadans le fond on aurait pu
cocommencer plus vite la dose de
rarappel. Lui suggérer de prende
plplus de temps pour lui pour se
coconcentrer sur ses idées et êe
cacapable d'avoir des opinions i
sosont un peu plus éclairées etl
rerefusait de le faire.
OnOn l'a un peu mis au pied du r
auaurait aurait des fêtetes. Ona
didit : Horacio, t'as vraiment
bebesoin de temps pour toi parce
quque ça nuit au conseil que tu
dodonnes et tu as le choix : ou
bibien ce qui est ou bien tu
prprends un mois de congé. Pas
trtrois semaines, pas de semain,
unun mois de congé.
IlIl est allé en réflexion, il a
paparlé avec sa conjointe en fin
dede semaine et lundi il est
ararrivé en disant : je ne veux
papas prendre un mois de congé n
plpleine vague comme ça, ça part
trtrès s mal. Je pense que je ss
mimieux de quitter et on a acceé
sasa démission.
- - Lutte, pour la population,
esest-ce que vous sentez autoure
vovous peut-êtrtre pas un désavu
mamais les gens commençaient à
êêtrtre agacés ou lessiver plus
didifficilement?
- - Oui absolument. Mais des
didirecteurs de la santé publiqe
ququi ont fait des erreurs
d'd'appréciation, de jugement à
trtravers le monde, il n'y en a
papas un qui est blanc comme
neneige. Docteur Fauci
a a fait des erreurs aux États-
UnUnis. Il n'a pas été remplacé
popour autant. Comme Arruda dist
auau début de la pandémie que le
mamasque n'était pas idéal,
FaFauci a dit la mêmeme chose. e
didirecteur de la santé en Suèd,
onon l'a vu. Il y a des erreurs
paparce qu'il y a du nouveau. Ms
lele processus pour s'assurer
ququ'il n'y a pas d'erreur, c'et
papas d'envoyer quelqu'un se
rereposer ou de le renvoyer.
C'C'est de faire de la santé
pupublique un forum de discussin
inintègrgre et indépendant. C'ea
sasanté publique par exemple avt
eueu sa propre cellule de crise,
avavait consulté au code est un
enensemble de professeurs et de
mémédecins importants dans les
sysystèmemes... dans les hôpipix
momontréalais, québécois je veux
didire, le nombre d'erreurs aurt
étété réduit. Ce n'est pas ce qi
s's'est passé. Comme l'a signalé
PaPaul St-Pierre Plamondon serat
TwTwitter hier, Monsieur Arruda
fafaisait parti d'une équipe de5
pepersonnes dont il était le sel
rereprésentant de la santé
pupublique et les discussions
apapprenaient par cette équipe,
cecette cellule d'urgence. Il ny
a a pas juste des
ququestion de santé publique qud
onon prend une décision de fermr
unune route ou un bar. Il y a
auaussi de l'économie, le morale
lala population, etc. Mais il
ététait le seul. Il était isolé.
C'C'est facile à c ce moment de
cocommettre des erreurs quand tu
eses constamment sous le despot.
S'S'il avait été dans une équipe
ququi a aurait envoyé ses
coconsultations après s étude, y
auaurait eu moins d'erreurs.
- - Est-ce que c'est le moment e
chchanger les règlgles du jeu? y
a a ce débat depuis le début.
EsEst-ce qu'on ne devrait pas
séséparer davantage les
rerecommandations de la santé
pupublique, qu'elles soient
exexposées plus clairement et qe
leles décisions politiques qui
seseront toujours ultimes soient
elelle aussi séparée, qu'il n'ya
papas des points de presse collr
cocomme ça? Est-ce que c'est le
momoment où pas?
- - C'est-à-d-dire qu'en tempêt,
popour une ou un directeur de la
sasanté publique, ça requiert dx
chchoses : la politique et la
cocompétence. Je regrette, maise
pepense que Monsieur Arruda a
dédémontré encore une fois pas a
prpremièrere vague, on peut
papardonner beaucoup de choses à
lala premièrere vague, mais des
ererreurs qui se sont répétées
dedepuis, des erreurs graves qui
onont désinformé la population r
dedes moyens quand mêmeme assez
fofondamentaux de se protéger,
inincluant la contagion par
aéaérosols, la ventilation, etc.
SaSa branlée : dans d'autres
prprovinces par exemple Colombi-
BrBritannique, la docteure
inindépendante politiquement. Ee
a a été applaudie pour sa gestin
dede la premièrere vague.
DeDernièrerement elle est trèss
crcritiquée. Il y a eu un
glglissement de compétences aus.
EsEst-ce que c'est l'usure? Dans
soson cas je ne sais pas.
DoDonc sa prend les deux.
JeJe prendrai la compétence ente
leles deux maisons peux avoir ls
dedeux, ce serait encore mieux.e
rereprends aussi l'idée dans Dre
PaPayette qui est un chercheur n
imimmunologie renommée qui a
susuggéré il y a plusieurs jour:
lala constitution d'un comité
avaviseur indépendant avec des
spspécialistes, donc vraiment
inindépendant du pouvoir politie
popour aviser non seulement les
prpremier ministre, mais le
miministre de la santé. Si les
prpremier ministre continuent à
rerefuser ça, une fois que
MoMonsieur Arruda n'est plus das
lele portrait, c'est il y a
d'd'autres problèmemes dans la
gegestion de la pandémie, il n'y
auaura plus personne d'autre à
popointer que lui-mêmeme.
- - Alec, est-ce que c'est le
momoment d'envisager des
chchangements d'organigramme, de
crcréer une distance entre la
sasanté publique et le ministèr?
- - Je suis assez d'accord avece
quque Luc disait à s savoir qu'l
n'n'y a pas beaucoup d'endroits
dadans le monde qui ont été
irirréprochable. Il y a beaucoup
d'd'endroits où on a une
séséparation entre l'expert en
sasanté public et le gouvernemet
etet ça n'a pas nécessairement
mimieux performé, pages aux Éta-
UnUnis. La troisièmeme vague en
OnOntario a été une catastrophe.
EnEn Alberta, ça a été extrêmemt
didifficile aussi. José parle de
lala Colombie-Britannique. Chaqe
vavague est différente d'une
prprovince à l l'autre. Est-ce e
l'l'indépendance donnerait quele
chchose de plus? Peut-êtrtre, p-
êêtrtre pas. Je suis plus ou mos
cecertaine de ça. Ça donne un
popouvoir au contraire d'êtrtres
prprès s du premier ministre por
ququ'on soit capable d'êtrtre ds
lala cellule de crise et
d'd'influencer les décisions du
prpremier ministre plutôt t quee
fafaire des conférences séparée.
CÇa n'avait pas encore ne peut
papas améliorer les choses. Il a
dedeux choses qui peuvent êtrtre
fafaites. Peut-êtrtre pas les
prpremier ministre, mais
cecertainement que le nouveau
didirecteur de la santé publique
etet un comité plus large. Arrua
trtravaille beaucoup avec sa
pepetite équipe. Les membres ont
ququitté cet automne, ça a
dédéboussolé Monsieur Arruda.
EÉlargir l'entourage de Luc
BoBoileau, d'avoir peut-êtrtre n
cocomité différent pour l'aidert
ququ'on est des séances techniqs
d'd'information quand il y a des
grgrosses séances qui soient
memenées par la santé publique
avavant la conférence de presse
popour qu'on puisse poser des
ququestions plus techniques.
- - En conclusion rapidement?
- - Aussi que les directeurs dea
sasanté publique rencontraient s
papartis d'opposition. Il doit
ininformer aussi les partis
d'd'opposition de sa vie, de ses
coconseils, etc. Ça ne peut pas
cocontinuer non plus à r restern
vavase clos comme salée depuis e
dédébut.
- - On reste un peu sur le mêmee
susujet parce que lundi, il y a
unune décision importante qui
totouche les parents : les écol.
EÉcoutez bien la prochain
exextrait. Mêmeme si on part les
écécoles, c'est la mêmeme sujet
ququ'elle indépendance.
- - Je l'ai toujours dit, puis e
l'l'ai dit clairement au nouveau
didirecteur national; ça reste
mama priorité le retour à l l'é.
DrDr LUC BOILEAU, dir. national
sasanté publique du Qc par intém
- - Moi, j'assume que cette
fofonction-là d doit êtrtre
inindépendante et dans
l'l'exercice que j'anticipe
fafaire, elle le sera.
- - J'ai trouvé ça révélateur.
LuLuc, je commence avec vous. Il
didit : je l'ai dit au nouveau s
rérédacteurs de la santé publiq,
àà q quel point c'était importat
popour moi que les écoles ouvret
lulundi matin. Lui, il doit faie
soson avis jeudi. Est-ce que c't
unune bonne idée aubade {à e ene
nonon Luc?
- - J'allais justement parler de
çaça. Il n'y a pas d'organisatin
ididéale. Il faut tenir compte
auaussi de la personnalité du
prpremier ministre la personnalé
dudu premier ministre est de
coconsulter. Il l'a fait avec
NoNoël. La décision de la santé
pupublique devait arriver le 16
dédécembre, le 1er décembre, ila
didit : j'aimerais bien avoir 20
pepersonnes assises à t table.
LaLa santé publique a acquiescé
quque c'est impossible.
- - Est-ce que ça a été
rérévélateur? Bien sûr r qu'en t
dede ligne, c'est le gouvernemet
ququi va décider. Personne
reremettre en question. Mais es-
cece que ça ne atteinte pas la
dédécision qui va arriver des
LuLucques Boileau d'entendre ça
alalors qu'il est à 1 1 m de lu?
- - Je pense que ça peut avoir e
ininfluence. En mêmeme temps, oa
élélu un gouvernement qui prend
dedes décisions et celui qui va
êêtrtre jugé sur sa déesse gestn
dede la pandémie.
CÇa a toujours été la priorité u
QuQuébec de garder les écoles
ououvertes. François Legault s'n
vavante en disant : on a gardé s
écécoles ouvertes plus
ququ'ailleurs. Ça ne veut pas de
quque les Boileau et son équipe
sosont obligés de dire oui. Il a
dedes manièreres de rouvrir les
écécoles de manièrere plus
sésécuritaire avec des protocols
didifférents ou les experts vont
didire : la réalité du
gogouvernement, c'est de garder
leles écoles, est-ce qu'on est
cacapable? Est-ce qu'on peut
amaméliorer les choses? Il faute
fifier à l la personnalité de Lc
BoBoileau. On va voir de quel bs
ilil se chauffe.
- - La taxe sur les non vacciné,
jeje vais vous entendre. Josée?
- - Les piègeges et la mêmeme ds
plplusieurs mois c'est-à-d-diree
lele premier ministre dit d'un
ccôtété : je suis celui qui
dédécédait. C'est normal, c'est
lului qui est élu. En mêmeme te:
jeje suis toujours les
rerecommandations de la santé
pupublique. Il est le temps quee
prpremier ministre... tant qu'ie
vava pas démêleler sa propre
cocontradiction et s'en tenir tt
sisimplement à : : oui je prends
coconseils de la santé publique
mamais je suis les dernièreres
prprends des décisions et voici
popourquoi. C'est sûr r que même
DoDocteur Boileau va êtrtre un u
pipiégé.
- - Taxe pour les noms vaccinés,
c'c'est une bonne idée ou pas?
- - J'aurais préféré une
obobligation vaccinale. La taxeà
totoutes sortes de défauts.
PrPremièrerement, il faut dire e
çaça satisfait beaucoup de monde
paparce qu'enfin, on s'est dit :
onon est tous pris dans
l'l'embouteillage et il y a une
vovoiture qui passe sur la voie
d'd'accotement à d droite et qua
crcréer plus d'embouteillage pls
loloin, on est tous fâchchés. Ms
dadans l les hôpipitaux, on avas
ararrêt t exemple de ça, la
sisituation est bien différente.
LeLes médecins travaillaient. Ce
n'n'est pas tout le temps ce gee
dede personnage qui i n'est pas
vavacciné, mais aussi des
ititinérants, des personnes avec
des déficiences, des personnes
ââgégées. Il y a de tout dans la
sosociété qui se ramasse à
l'l'hôpipital. Pour ces gens, je
susuis pas certaine qu'une
cocontribution financièrere...
- - Alec là-d-dessus?
- - C'est une mesure qui peut
sesembler attrayant mais qui est
ququand mêmeme compliqué. Je nes
papas répéter ce que Lucas vient
dede dire parce que c'est vrai.
CeCeux qui ont des moyens
fifinanciers assez faibles pour
ququi des milliers de dollars,
c'c'est de l'argent que tu ne px
papas mettre dans la nourriture.
C'C'est peut-êtrtre un peu plus
cocompliqué dans la réalité même
sisi c'est populaire. Est-ce que
c'c'est légalement possible? Je
pepense que oui. Il y a des anns
popour le faire. Mais c'est
cecertain que dans les détails,l
fafaudra que ce soit très s bien
amaménagé pour que ça soit
apapplicable.
- - Josée?
- - Je suis pour la vaccination
obobligatoire, la loi sur la saé
pupublique les permet. On est ps
zézéro Québec à l le penser. One
pepeut pas dire aux personnes :
c'c'est votre choix de vous faie
vavacciner ou non et en mêmeme s
onon va vous taxer après s si vs
nene l'êtetes pas et que vous
ututilisez le systèmeme de sant.
C'C'est un ou l'autre.
- - Vous êtetes que ce serait ps